delicious I was on our reddit discussion
forum this morning at david pakman.com
slash reddit there's really good
conversation happening there i am on our
reddit discussion forum producer pat is
on our reddit discussion forum let's
look at some interesting discussions
that caught my eye this morning at david
pakman.com slash reddit there was a post
which inquired isn't david better off
without youtube revenue it always struck
me that the show could never be truly
independent if it was taking cash from
ad revenue listen it was as independent
as we could be we had no contact with
advertisers we just do content and then
youtube would bring the advertisers we
wouldn't know what advertisers were
going to show up that day there was
really no way that we could be
compromised but the truth the silver
lining in the YouTube ad boycott is if
we can replace the lost revenue through
membership and patreon then we'll
certainly be better off because then we
don't have to care what we're going to
choose is 2d monetize we'll just say hey
we don't we don't we're not expecting
any money from YouTube we're going to do
every story exactly the way we want to
do it without any regard for whether it
might be adult content and that was the
beauty of the system that we had because
all the advertiser appeal and reach and
all that stuff was done on youtubes end
we have to do any of that didn't have to
do any didn't have to spend any time
trying to sell ads right it just they
showed up there we worked on the content
also on our reddit discussion forum what
Pat were no I'm sorry whoa Pat is
physically intimidating when standing
yeah a lot of people were reacting Pat
to our behind-the-scenes video that we
did showing what goes on here before the
show and people were taken aback by your
height and they found you physically
imposing Wow yeah I'm like 62 63 writing
i'm not too physically imposing right
yeah i mean i find generally i'm not
scared of pat in studio except for on
rare occasions right speak about that we
don't really talk about what those
situations are so anyway people noticing
that having a good time with that unread
it also from our reddit discussion forum
david pakman finally speaks spanish on
his livestream yeah you know the on the
live streams there would be a lot of
hyperbolic statements about David speak
Spanish now blah blah blah and growing
up as an immigrant
the u.s. I'm particularly one who
doesn't fit the stereotype of what
spanish speakers look like wrong an
incorrect stereotype people would often
say Oh speak Spanish to prove you know
how to speak Spanish or sort of like as
a side show so I became very resistant
growing up when people would say speak
Spanish like as a game of sorts but
people have been asking questions in
Spanish be a super chat on the live
streams and I'll read them in ants read
them translate them and answer them like
I don't have a problem speaking Spanish
it's just that I don't like doing it as
a sort of sideshow you know what I mean
right because language is just the means
of communication it's not something that
you show up yeah it's very very weird
and so anyway it's not that I've been
resistant it's just if there's really no
reason to speak Spanish why would I and
lastly how do we defeat online trolls
this is an interesting conversation that
started after an article from the
Atlantic was posted to our reddit
discussion forum and I encourage you to
participate because this is an issue
we've talked a lot about so there's
something for everybody on the David
Pakman show ready discussion forum I
encourage you to go to david pakman.com
slash reddit sign up you can suggest
interviews for the show topics talk to
other people we also are now running a
discord server where you get the
information for the server on reddit and
then you sign up for discord and viewers
and listeners Pat are actually talking
to each other I think we should actually
figure out what this discord server
thing is all about I created an account
and oiled because it got too complex for
me but I'm kind of kidding but I haven't
dug into it yet but we should show up
there one day I'd be a little nervous
would you yeah see the audience face to
face I'm used to just seeing a camera
well it's voice to voice right it's not
nobody would see you they would hear you
ok I can just think I can handle you can
handle it yeah we're going to look into
that but anyway a lots going on on
reddit so sign up there david pakman.com
slash read it and please contribute
making continue making those
contributions at patreon.com slash david
pakman show